друзі всім доброго вечора раді психами
that i c платформами ціна bid ринку
міністерства святі наука україни я її
модератор владимир страшко екзо в 20
роки не жартую дня виходу в ефір з вами з
толку і macy's веденому українцям це
державним ідея чим або щоб знати
звернешся виїжджається в крайнє як
можна ніби їй курис там і сьогодні у нас
пінну світу і легендарну дена можна так
сказати йогор дідківський меценат повернувся
в бізнесмен то професор на ігри
vitara вас після такого уявлення
труба по мультиметру ти
думаєш andreea banica ми на памір а ти
ти ти точно на вам ось алое про про на
гарного це стукають coupe чернів у нас
12 раніше не сьогодні завершився ви не
здаєте я гаряча фаза ті та восьмеричного
видно почала зі знову і ми запитуємо а
традиційного наших гостей як у вас
проходить зараз ще нового ніж
займається сидять за стріла і тоді
там вона зараз не проходьте це теж на
сімейну то вірно і тут у мене вже все
ретельно можеш здолати ти можеш
складових про вас корисним водних
виразкову дна і мені нормально але мамі
табір пробачу йому той найдовший варіант
хлопчика чашок вирішив закінчити навіщо і
чітко парі можемо захищати на годину
просто вимагали хочеться літа лави
депозити і вона збираюся падати духом
мені ще до прямої стежки україни привести
ліві сили та рублю
козацький drive не нададуть і нас тепер за
раз так диво кузанського драйву я вас
побачивши позавчора у формі весь килим може
дістатися 1 310
втілити і англійської абсолютно точно
майдан
національні збори я видно
29 протягом 2014 року принцип кому дому
убити настей український народ
українському народу через дітей і вбив і
молот чистим і правого сектора ми довго
бідністю меню захарченка дописати руки
в'язниці
прямо по телевізору патина дроїдів тег
стиль пін-ап всього їй важливим родом
тобто однакові по чому савина знаємо
так самі вікна майдані мілітарі в
національної гвардії
1000 в день крут пам'яті в цьому крут ми
хочемо назад але ось підбиралася це
перша група спеціального значення в
було вже потім якщо ми не називаючи хотів
печатку романтично навіть досі боїшся
таких бусах руб цикли виступив їх більше
раз
вони хочу надати частку з тієї ж суми
розумний був цей об'єкт у нас назвав і
паралельний воїни
воланів лісу чітко вовчара потім під
супер та був його палату би там кулаки ми
плюс він і зайшла з думаю за сару на осях
і на шеврон їх носом гуру нурука і
цру навчилися roi ви знаєте що знаю
роботі всім у тебе чим і
весело і займаємося
172 воїнів 74
хірургії часом від нього
так ccc точно сюди у вовки став отримавши
ви не знаєте така аналогія знає він на
дурник дурень на як вкажіть на просто
так ти сунув його настає за раз і кима
бачимо сюди символ ліфтів філософії та
філософ здається все так багато буду
користуватися в тому числі і босів і че
за раз випадає, а не як у людей по
тротуару
дають школу вдавитися божу волю ти
якби ми не намагалися тут євро чи не
розумієш і так і по ТК
я не розумію тут я зі мною та руїни їх
obtain і неролі б просто просторі малих
лимон і побутові солдати, які завжди
холод страх і слове
мета
lz77 щоб впоратися додамо дозволить і
вимоглива в курсі ще й 1
базова дистанційна школа новачків ми
23 передали лютору білий з українців
родовитий бюро девід вчителя
двадцяти двох предметів меню завис
тепер ми в п'ятницю люблять нові ви про
новий пахло фурор нас
1004 подала заявки самсу кований fpm
нового 4-я я сказав конфуцій ще
якісь держави імператор позначається
залишенням ділити них людей, що йдуть або
ну так розуміє і за аналогією з Україною
і знову я став і так оскільки замовлень
чим мої слова та закони плавають свято
маси милі зла там у нас наші наче
руна вправно дубового вилка та й у
карткові опиші називають лавром випадку
син гармонію людині че на
ринку зараз я не показав і ти одно сам
людиною будь здоровий щоб пом'ята це
солоку ніш перед злом то цей прийшли
всі якірний розум і особливо духовні
значущості і чорт і староста що вони
хотіли with safe
with mature український нападаючого крем
старий з ними таких продуктах і ось
чотирнадцятому шістнадцятому стоїть експо
складу при 180 тисяч до досконалого
єпископом
стомлених а дружньому такі гарні
військові тріски були
видно з роду які у нас українська
Фінам cm так філософ просто розбавити
вечірню з нього так директор ще не знаю
чого ми часто не змивати був я
розумію принцип я філософ знаєш що не
можемо напевно прийшла в сексі для ви
реально зараз розповість допоміг нам
арешти поля у нас чи відвернуся, а чому
я люди породити там під час аналізу ситуації
заради світу через петлі процес mod 6
числа вставала до війни на геть ради
там ризикую національними сором та вина
університету річки вийшов чотирнадцятому
зростання в повному складі screen ну я кину
будемо чергувати, якщо братом такого
крутого роду та на сомалі корпорації
героя україни колишній син джемільова випав
чубарів таким ще потім і за вас за
Дещо ми покараємо що ні на що
більше дітей перст просто дтп виймати
навички та компетенції і ми нещодавно на
чому я готовий шістнадцятим істориком ми
адже новини індустріальні свиті носа
світлова панель управління відразу ж нас
просто світлова улюблений тихий
вакцина проти але поки що порушник цими
речі не а от як усі речі скажемо свято
я хотів би якраз навіть добрий шви cdma
підняла просто поговорить історія жити а
ми на її друг у нього син які
призначається в третьому курсі за один раз
покараємо і не здається ще мого сина на
буду вищим якщо ти до чогось що перший
урок відсіку вигляд не одразу не увійшов членів
чайник, ніж вона в чайнику, стояк сильної
проходить окисні проходьте за раз вина та
так само так само історія дано було
навчання за розтікаючись ну там шість на
мага і труби так ось таке поважають на
стейки ось сівби стане ривок і за
більш ніж ринув Іван і на я кисті
свити наших дітей дтп за раз
я хочу вашого доступу або світити на
монетою світлі
зарості тотальний крах і піднімемо
показав він здивуєтесь університет
у неї з інструкції захоплення універсальних
знань почуття заходитимуть через
болонську систему набагато заміж за нього
слова майбутній міністр суми роті з
командою дадуть цим придумав і будьте
предметний іспит щоб мордва любить
його так я покараю тебе, а мама не тарифи
за чехами вибираю три предмети їх штурм
і тобі раніше нмоль ayudame сердець і
поліфункціонального свято клуб ска була
права то ви
леніну за люблю чернявська світлана
ма-ама youtube на їх раша
завантажте британія налаштуваннями та купили
вона була поліфункціонального треба було
пастка професора ван вона була там я не
побачиш ці кабінкам тече чекаю за
машинерії щелеп марксизм-ленінізм йому
ширший інший закон Ньютона тому у
смітів загострити учує саме свято та я
просто петанк свої шиї мама така куди
Відразу вся квитанція мета ілюзія та відблиски
на самій ведуться іди ти ведуться гід і
продовжують жити без вікторії далі а
депозиту здалеку на планеті чим саме
контракті а би читаю що він і 30
дипломом нічого не знаєш все квітами
корпорації повернути пам'ять лівих та
лінивих людей
лікувального досить вузу розповімо про
паска вершина москві пан долар мозку
капот скоєно в неї вже 12 руки посох
беруть більше ніш кадиров щоки бог
одягати значить чи можна дні взагалі знати
історію мудрості і всі валюти
марчевський концепції святих днів і
політичні релігії неекономічні
їжі відразу мишу такі масони що такі
ренесанс що такої культурної революції
ще такі за розрахунок виплат економіки в
гарячому сексі святі як утворюється на
світлі індустріальний ти була свята
ринок у смаку та посміхаючись на робітник
день латиф ан 300 заганяю ціль вона у нас
ніяких чого 806 прийшла руті видно
вивозить крипа старому сколі малі
російські царі і могли 3000 ручаються
кріпака було сам подолали травми
ефективно було робочий уклад там Іван
iii адже порожні ви шукали ви ще рабство
на заводі чим мостам відлетиш з попси і
декаре буду ванесса мей комуни з
індустріальні ви майже виникла
цифровий комп'ютер шляхом після правових
соціальні світи і жирні раз міцний у
назара див це економіка народ просто
Саша йому живіть можемо вирішити бізнесмен
видом і крутиш шукаємо бізнесмен із бобом
все одно виділяє п'ять тут туза раз
українців немає ну я поливаю і в тому їх
придумати на фарбу чіпляти фольгу щоб
тепловізор набравши чиїхось може припаяти
лулав одноразовий low ширину великих
тому ж стріляти за міс танки впали
струмом крем українців і потім на те там
опинюся на трату але не пущена грушею
або зірками чому батарея вами
пресвітлим танком і атака trash команда
підсихає натискати на клан через
п'ятнадцять що москали зуби новини
бензинки через дуже просто перекрити
всі команди до 16 їх у мене 3 розділ
можна собі заснути у статуті ким наговор
на по фламандському ну і хлопці моя рота
технічне забезпечення купували
додали 4 видані фріман просто головний
розроблений набагато разове в icann
вони були висновки на 1 куль ну і кинули
прийшов обидва і критий один раз не пульнув
alive атака захлинулась що спеціальна
батарея сива щоб всі враг закупаєте
головним і вистрілити суєти multicon'a
все на що є гармата 3 бабуся
переспівую я вам чесно скажу ми міняємо
навіть смаку шуму приїжджаю на що я я
слухав британці до жучок якщо провини ви але
навіть хочеш і українською інструктори 3
на вали британські віскози будуть
підніметься концепції віддачі великих
йовича її київ 10 практиці вийшла з
хронік так і називалася ніби майже все
схили в карпатах precor партії але
сінок і немає цього did it 66 ерік астані
вишку то він переміщається і так само як
550 кеш обороті та й вирішив сюди до нашої
ери since 2000 скроня персидський цар превью
такі цифри вийшло 20 тисяч сімсот тисяч
підривати в той час у ступах the bat
різних трієру 3 роки дар'я ви у нас
за 1 один води майже півтора місяці
місяць прошу не буду гриньова згладжування
добра бат і самі після бізнес та вусами
посипте спиці самі по собі кожен
калідум об'єкт hotel zara слова було вже
пройшло бойові слони були грали штаб
самі керуючи обробляє оборони з
якісними вже ніч strappy а
ось півночі слюди і каспер сьогодні ви обидва
забрали
я
все-таки інстинкт просто людей
трусики та тестостерону що ти розумієш
що вже нічого нативно просто повз все
стежки низькою на
комусь
українці так люблю тому шуя кумис
придумав тисячі п'ятому уроці ховатися я
і нас дасть і
казанський батальйон
таки нашої нації тисячі тисяч людей
вийшов і нація ніхто ціни президент
наприклад дай бог не палить ціні столітті
я тикаю
правда і україни воюй не воюй, а ви тут
нічого страшного був ми стали народом
гулагом обличчі орбітальна коротше
українці зламалася матриця матриця
міжнародного права за нас кинув цих
народних на будапештський б баран
меморандум отримувати ще ми
просто ви міжнародному
законодавству навісну друзі давав
нам і до
4 до 5 грудня 94 руку США виділяла 20
мільярдів дуру на протистояння 43
ракет не армія до столу при
полюванні на леонід макарович те, що йому
небесне
просто здам 43 ракетну армію разом
будівельник стегнових потенціалів не
підтікав і лавиною момент вона підключена
було б вини за живого застосовувала жити і
тут такі сайти
і по папері і кинув нічого не пом'ятий я
торкаюся з німецьким послом здатна
статус ще в 2005 р. ефективно нейтралітет
пішов економічність республіки чечня
нікуди бека запускаємо поля bambino
чи заражена дмитрия ті питати
akinator та
гліцин yamaha психіки наш народ буде те
захар беркут то інший сміта вами на
чотири українські фронти на територію до
або тепер таких мереж уже розпродано
через сорок натякніть через сварок про
кіно висоли грубо щоб прокинутися на
територію прямо і сном чи цифру україни
та але ви там і сімейним насильством sautron
і баштами дітьми ну монет, що дарує на
придатні стику претензія до
цивілізованих я його і вона я на вигляд
медяк Вільямса з
елемент із трьох панд ірма совістю
кидаються він вчиться ви не знаєте як
вважаю що там така то безглуздо отримала
виступати і 2020 уроку встигати на
Нивках метрів був чорним не ну нам
ніякі pr кого напружуються всі
бориса всі приїхали сюди
розповідає деві був і до вивісимо рибу
ловили на двд був не тільки льодовикові
хлопці hidden та ми вас туди не посилав
губи все-таки знають про прозріння з
[музика]
кадру , 6 а тут я як ринок разів два
досвіду не я щось ціле де що можна ті
це зарита добре добитися перший актор
шайа історія така штат висловить e-pro
1000 святого на мову обидві знаком чудо
вінник я тут же фріман паралель з геєм
і 1938 руку очей покараю чикулі там пан
чим berlingo стиснувши швагер за панель nvidia
mayan відвозять політику наших китайських
перевірили вона скаже в одесі ялинки або
під
все промо
чому черчиллю за ви союзу вийшов все
просто там вже була на міліметри вигляд
краху рік би просто черчилль по п'яні по
куріння сигарної випадково вінсом і
здаватися не стояв що там
застудилися у нас варіанті уваги я
зносю тяжко я чую їх багата і
оснащені хвилини волею асташової
виявити радянської в крові але поки
смикнути версію синтезу вбити сам щоб
були на стікалися 353 катя мене цокають
мобільне технологічно армія ви майже
одна рота дроні виріж і при низькому
рівні країни на китайському усушки
вертоліт тисячам про наших пише вже не
your time над ми вирішуємо дрону хіба
днк трон коміка тону on titan
так все просто звичайний паперові всупереч
для оператора б живої етики хортів з
відомого хоукай і незабаром збиток держава
навчилася носилася брати українську, а не
повезу утробу піднімати українське свято
персі до поля функціонально додається
слово національні до стійки та умов
кібер у стеку кібератак та кібер
спортсмен вона більше не такі фахівці
топ таки займаються кібер експансії ми
не тикатимемо
софта чисто ринку у мене до коханого
москву ви прослухаєте у нас є такі
звуки йшло видерти це просто складок
просто вкладати крихти викласти
українських нових актив перекладати в
сферу
промислові фарби та промислові рибні
з ти куди нам щастя для
мотобура намети б продати українською
дивом а ну я знайшла чи чекаю на такі зустрічі
труби брат tywin рубля edge turbo вниз та
здачу національних інтересів людську
цивілізації виглядав як
чомусь ідею української наук вівці
назвала ю чена тягну і розрив кай і
принципі потенціал ну як ус намотав
консенсусу цієї консенсус вчитель хімії
між бізнесом українським то наука це
паралельно, що навіть мало ноу-хау
знаходять свій вигляд бродінню практично
серією стою і може заробити у нас
люблять і розпоряджаються бюджет
інтелектуальний жлоб
просто жлоби кулони або 30 років я вкажу
це макросі клубом у ти тупиш злості
купити потрібно bentley на продажі рушити
почуттям червона розвивати наука center
десятиліттям укладають я вам
розповідала дня як ми забуваємо
діоксидом помічник старости дають заслуг
зі стримом вузький і виявляє і в молекулі
води термодинамічно видихом ви бути від
виводитимете мікроелемент
не
їх то з несуть не з усяких комедію
всяких
вірусних захворювань за цим за хворобу
іван літа замку дифтерії в
це дуже ролики з вершками наука
зустрічаються темні виїхав з почту
малинового школа інституті в моєму
ананасів критики діри чого скарбу та
університетах наноматеріали та
нанотехнології towa no sora no повністю
в Україні вона займалася звичним
вузлами просто виявимо їх не
76-річний вік та 50 руки на вибуття
люди та перерва на 3 угу імунного
статусу та вийшло наноматеріали
святого просто поміняти продумувати
звичну крою біосинтезу трильйон
спосіб і будь-яким і меню даного
воскрес і
релігія хочеш просто профілактичного
продовжити людям не вірю в добро і
любов природу то завтра сонце в стан
Оленою вірю в канадське агентство
виглядає формальних і людей я займаюсь
наукою орлиця нових оверлок шипкова
наука вдумайтесь за 1 ну я займаю міні
реалізував і воду від тієї масами свої
кисломолочка молока силу вже й для армії
на зуби вихлоп
пишемо місцям коли є більше над
негорюча краса і на корейський троянд я
дізнаюся що наша експансія в науці там у
кого я написав схилам 2005 і ротик
камінців плавно розшук україни може
бути
мільйон гурток наростав
емоційна нація відвантажуватись ще
основи і при цьому бюджету є святим
культури все частіше матиме рацію до
висловила всі наші зуби багато в чому взяв і
забрала всіх міністерств 117 мільярдів
дубовими стяжками барон в принципі
логічним хлопчик там логічний хіт
україні та києві на вул означає дітей у нас
шістсот шістдесят сім тисяч кулер і
замішаний українці еманацій з половиною
мільйона переміщених людей насаджених
на улюблених видних весь я знаю км і
стартовий
чоловік старту на ми готуємось ми
вибираємо крадіжок їх 4 ми прив'язуємо
онлайн до дистанції б люди плутають і що
ти перекладаєш кришку
цифру так гітлера читають не книжку
цифр
припинення просто психолога є
що в результаті нутро без двох рук його
до п'ятого класу
2015 по-перше причиною гормональних
вимагати пускати просто вид пускати у
кого на цьому блукають вивчаються хто краще
хто дівчатка якого любить про це зло
старших класах вантажі на сфолив
занурити я коваль ю а
після навантаження та навантажувати по
відвідувачам ризикували кімнаті каравани
займатися не люблю всіх чорний + дима
rusia ти шумами і так знаю чи так цінуєте
кого але скільки ну що ти не про пункт
ножі про пульку знаю засіб там ще
одну 3 роки 60 3 ж бізнес та робота за
немов консолі та бору
[музика]
t3 3g пиздато вигляд і на дуді користі
формується любов і по-звірячому 0,7
видавати а потім крапок ластівчин breach
купку захоче і видно хто схильний бути
божими лідер долара так а мама тітонька
старший брат якісь виховувалися
давай там трохи єдиного наших петлі viva
адже дитину природа більше ви нас ще не
знаємо вигляд і на порозі вона чисто це була
постелено чисто дашка шутер напишеш
довга губка там всякі дурниці слова
новий при повторі опробуй це і дати
відразу всякого
формули чайки здійснити і людині з
групи вона вже кайфу не я знаю я чоловіка
знати нас будуть чомусь або спробувати
та буду бути com вантажте таким чином
тримати його здати це сама свердлила
вже по-барабану я думаю що буду клину
бік самого світло у мене до вас чи
компанія за стеком звивини
розмішуватися таких цілей за абсолютно
мер там і знання на конкурентів як я
вважаю фінанси і це
що всі
історію що ж покажи книжку на youtube
каналу імені шевченка все це історія
вважаєш ось фізику читаючи
павла віктор в
ришельєвському ліцеї vds сибірському 4 с
копійками перекладі і вбиватися заходиш
в особі і там пекін лондон діти старших
класів займало все більші самі
якісь хочеш я походжу через таких
умів стріляти. це наш
вчитель фізики і відразу це серйозна з
знає і більше і педантичні вимкнені
у паніці нікуди не надходять я хочу
поміняти пораниш її, що там поранив підлогами
баті ключі розповідаю що захисту
базового ціна плюс бога-сина пільбург а
за раз таки і на цій загнав і цінними
ми чорні їх їм збитки пресують
директора пресуємо та району пресуючи та
департамент висвітлить вчитель нам уже про
іванчик вся нічого з розчину на такій
середу ще в родовід школі щоб будуть на
екрані в 4 плюс двадцять п'ять
університетів дорівнюють світ адреса
школи і ви будете щосуботи прямо
перед іграми можете приїхати визнавши
описавши зайдіть самі накачування всім
тільки скажіть київ 3 університеті
зациклений день дико бояться ходити
не сетом плюс наші родовичі паніку на
розмір правда логістом управи аспірантам
Будвар джигіт надходять на бюджет таким
чином і відро давида рація забудете про
українській 1000 плачу дітям такі радара
Девід стипендії квіти на магістра їдеш
і роздавили стенді наск оранта тільки
повний цикл
літачки та програмі яким його жалить
виграло дівчисько юридичні аспекти
трансплантології
300000 він як аспірантура є
мостом тисячі причин їх прямими тисячі
сердець вона за і закону нам адресу там
байкер ще раз би вся мама за зло love
Білорусь борщу серця наводить чіпи
шатку і вшивають в Україні ось так а
далі мені навіть не знаю чим вторинний
ефект обидва бійця що у китаї у святому
ринку впав і ціна на ворони шорки критим
x поливу своїх remover він і справді там
про шляхи органи ви б не хотів щоб
ми їхньому принципі в такому вигляді їм
запозичені невеликий
картині буря то виходить ви якщо така
ілюзія
ви бурять як я радий пом'ята це панда
бутків зон газів така сама в
чотирнадцятому навчанню п'ятнадцятому уроці
слуху важкою думою це буде завалено
згущаючи святу що подібного на такі
кілька стей занурюючи за 1 травня нове за
україні там буде купити в україні коли
шкірний напій стала університетом
поплавського той шок
для мого
друга назад і виксе відкрив по важливо
люблю на старшого героя україни
ректор острівський до теми та річки його
Демидович врятували але для монет
хвилини різних таких служб у
авто авторитету ще й світло є
шуригіна за 26 рахунки князь острозький
поранив його цитаделі
1576 у роті та любина завданням термін бачу
на видному лакоблі там монетам
культурний шок на місце пасивну річкам
на американської крихти любові до вмирає
адже даю телефони не церкви буду цих
канадського агентства з продажу чаю
спускаючи скрини духовність вдалося
приватний комплекс андрея
інклюзивних і блядських січні
там космос там забилося кріс ми б ви
там не міністр будемо ми просто дали б
вийшов перекинеш курити нервів
результату дисней сама балансу я хто ви
а плюс
університету курінного приводу суду
мигдалики світлові народжуєш саме просто
обман обідки бачить і цілком мети
надав геродот але знай стоїмо у неї
почалися багата знаєш ну занепалих людей
запізнюємося і вирішив ще глибини допоможемо і
тепер справа вільної знати це запах я
клінтон toyota rav coupe інформація що
ти його не нас тут то прийміть назад
про помилку тема та капчі уссурі дітей
студенту шуману вважаю дверей офіцер
примічай відключення прийняти батьки пряма
пишуть чи може біля яхти ми йшли приймати
мирного нам житло червоні буде включено і
адже вас не культур не
психологічно горизонтального
людьми суму дико
козаки ти прийняв давав через включення
тубіста варіанті у позбавлення досвіду про співака
або небеса епіцентру проблеми в центрі
проблеми спраги душевого а в край ви
проблеми повинні
ми хочемо на увазі потім за те, що ми
можна задавити на дивані обсі баталії
іван імітую і так пішов я дуже дякую
злочинна коротша сьогодні ми друг
яків дубай дорівнює україні та 30 дворів та
проживу якими здав американський паспорт
і написав заявку на який нам вдасться
вищий пілотаж
скажімо у царя скачуть дорівнюватиме україни
32 рот і живі в Україні немає дружбан
дружбан дивує американський паспорт
хочеш бути українець я вам скоро все
землян і при тому не захоче прийти за ту
прав за ти репетуєш, а нам чехова оля
золоті мільярди було повірте мені вже
знаємо валить дим уестом почитаю про рік
монету 3000 октарин продано землі земля
ціни на
російського з подільською категоріями та
товар на фінансовому та спекулятивному та
криптид на тес месію вдома sti українець
ви на було до нашого на батьківщині це та
буде псих
дохристиянською мишкою так і написано хто
захоче продати за леву про землю
прошили якийсь проливала за нею бронзовою
так круто кузова йому за рахунком ваш до
смерті
камінні політики цифра скажуть до римського
народу які народи посмішки та політики
штуки потім виявляються щоб на героїв
його народ
і ви як би народні воювали на мить
сунули ви і справді шрам від народу ківаю
поміряючи виїжджаючи ви прямо з 3 я звалю
думаю що в час покажемо принцип не
політична держава крові небо
політика для малини серйозно винесла
товариш ти хахаль його нею він особисто за
[ __ ] чи куються політик немає
ось його почти вже давно показав місяця
процедурі cr-mo демократія з чистого
стало вже охлократії та заарештувати і
зайвих просто ведемо тісь відьмака
переходьте сказав блазень
вивчають демократії на газ канал
серпня нітрохи безшовного її на літак
гори швейцарії фінальний і в японії я до
представлено збори таро храму ціна
найсильніших районі ці політики то нас
розлучень і
Кравчука значить навела потім розлучення
викручу кучма фатиме кучма симоненка
спраги ставлять два ці роки допомогою цуценя
або кошеня бути досвіду сам здивований і в
інший а там уже чарівні просили з
кожним блоком з'їлі шульги
народ кільки
охлократія і ви називають і демократії
охлократії цикли
вниз освітлення люди голосують у дані
відчуває ту поваляти я збив про вас не
потрібно може відтворити теплого на
вибирає по пробачиш
романтичного здатися потрапили знатися
наша все кожух лізе і тому як і мій
батько
начальнику жеку придуманому богу
попалить їх на стику тромбони вражати
феномен жити, а щоб дати свою частку
хумус коло хі і садити в неї чекати
винті безробітний хитромудрим взагалі своїм
йому простори частинах тоді за вижити
люди в інших море ален 30 рокки на 1 поверх
сама діви ну все за раз педаль
проголосуємо а ланцюг те щоб на
абсурд передавати свою частку в бучі та
струмки
затримки площа була біля vici
вечір голосував ці глави роду яких
були багатих дітей багатому ківано
обрала тільки три інакше ми вибрали два
з такої роботи професора серед вич і
1700 через 600 всім урок у vici та князь
сакульський
університетом інакше глашатай заведу
вожатий зуби і приймала їжу аргумент
повстання і залишився
там завидним усю операцію
то його увиливаю то ризиковий стануть а
вавіле повз коротше вислухала українці
краї нація кожен із вас може сказати
кайфанути і нас багату і ніхто у нас
вже з баб і
сонячної системи та ця позиція токсини
пізніше червові по планеті земля україна
викликано 9 то дюп україни
з-під гри буду мало за вашого до 30
наших poland закінчуватися переказами
навіть вам яскраву в душі так емоції хвилині
cola тобто. на чому подумати і я підірву вас
рибу затискати за україну
друзі всім світ але й навчитись була
платформа та масивного петрінгу мінус
вигляд і побачимо вуса завтра 20